Wolverine and Ghost Rider team up and
then they fight and then they team up
again they're like a high school couple
but this story is amazing now this
initially picks up with kind of a recap
to a degree that we don't need to go
super in-depth into suffice it to say in
the Ghost Rider stories Ghost Rider and
wolver rain have kind of been teaming up
a little bit and when I say team up I
simply mean that wolver rain ripped a
demon out of Ghost Rider's head but one
of the things that we're told here is
that the two of them have a lot of
history together and what this does is
this goes way back to the early days of
really Wolverine's career with the X-Men
over at the Xavier Institute and the
arrival of a kid named Bram now here's a
cool thing this kid is like he's like
the kid from The Omen right like
something's just a little off about him
and it's one of these things where no
one knows exactly what it is that's
going on but he is brought to the Xavier
Institute by a woman named a now of
course this leads to Wolverine showing
up popping his claws you know being all
intimidating and all that kind of cool
stuff this is back in the day when
wolver rain was like Old Testament so
like death and destruction wrath of God
that kind of thing but of course almost
immediately Xavier appears and then
tells Wolverine to leave and sits down
and starts talking with aah now what
happens here is as they have this
conversation she's not bringing him here
because she basically is going on the
assumption that he's a mutant she is but
she isn't it's really more that she just
doesn't understand what's happening with
him and she saw on TV how Xavier seemed
to be an expert in mutants and so in
turn she's asking him for some measure
of help now the reason why this is
important is this actually gives us a
time frame and this tells us it happens
around the time of Days of Future Past
which is to say when Xavier was making
the rounds on National Television trying
to publicize the peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants that kind of
thing but what AA says is that she's a
social worker who's been assigned to
bram's Case and all the other ones had
basically quit and she said that he'd
been in like a dozen foster homes but
things never seem to work out and she
says that there's just something about
him that scares other people things
happen around him they say pets die
people disappear some say they hear
strange noises a voice that doesn't
sound like his own that doesn't sound
human and of course she asks are you
able to help and one of the cool things
that kind of happens here and this is
actually a great throwback you end up
seeing like Nightcrawler teleport in
grab some ice cream and then like
teleport away kitty Pride shows up and
she's kind of upset about it and then
she leaves this is a throwback to the
Chris Claremont era of the Xmen because
he would do this all the time he would
see like these small little moments that
happen and it would kind of give a
really greater depth to what was going
on just in general with the X-Men at the
time right a lot of background stuff
happening so it was kind of fascinating
but Xavier chooses to read the mind of
this kid and when he does he's met with
a kind of force of energy that is
incredibly overwhelming now there's a
couple things to glean from this right
to the non- X-Men experienced person
they would just kind of say okay so like
it's a really powerful being but it's
immensely powerful and the reason for
this is that when it comes to Charles
Xavier even at this point in time his
telepathy was on a whole another level a
perfect example of this is when he got
into a psychic fight with the Shadow
King and that was the whole basis behind
the formation of the X-Men that he met
the Shadow King in Egypt the two of them
had a kind of psychic battle and then he
realized there are some beings out there
with incredible power that originate
with the kind of mutant Gene that will
just be straight up evil the Shadow King
is kind of like this force of evil that
exists out there right just like pure
darkness that exists in the Multiverse
but realizing that there are enemies out
there like that Xavier formed the team
in the first place the reality here
though is that this kid is not a mutant
and even Xavier says that right like if
this kid were a mutant I would do what I
could to help him but the reality is
that he's not what you're going to need
is somebody who really delves more into
the realm of magic and mysticism
possibly even demonology but the problem
here is aah gets frustrated at the idea
that there are no answers to be had and
ultimately feels as though she's kind of
being thrown away right just sort of
being dismissed by Xavier even for Bram
himself he's reluctant to leave he
doesn't want to go but he's sort of drug
away anyway now this is a very dangerous
precedent when it comes to the X-Men
Comics because anybody who knows
anything about mutants knows that when
when it comes to this kind of thing this
is when you start getting into like
Clyde wincham territory right just like
the Marquee of death this guy who was
able to wipe out universes with a wave
of his hand different things along those
lines cue every new comic book YouTuber
making a video about that
guy it is inevitably going to happen but
the thing about this is that it switches
over to Johnny Blaze in the early days
of his career which is to say when he
was basically just like a stunt man
going out there and Performing these
crazy Feats and of course as we know or
at least as most people are generally
aware of when it comes to Johnny Blaze
that he goes flying through the whole
stunt things go arai he ends up
basically finding himself in a position
where he's about to die he sells his
soul to the devil and then of course he
ends up becoming the new Ghost Rider the
caveat to all of this is that with this
being the early days of these two
characters their paths ultimately meet
but not right away instead what we
actually end up doing is picking up at
the orphanage where the director
basically tells Dr AA to just get rid of
bran because the other kids are
terrified of him and having him here is
putting the other kids in a situation of
high duress he knows that it's not like
the best thing to do but the reality is
that he just doesn't really seem to care
all that much and so in the midst of all
this really when there's like the
discussion of getting rid of him and the
other kids start waking up and really
seem intent on like doing Bram harm
Blood starts dripping onto aa's shoulder
and when they look up up and they get
into the room they end up finding that
Bram has just like twisted and mutilated
all these kids into like this just
monstrosity of a creature and they don't
even know how to interpret what it is
that they're seeing but that's why
things are popping off here is because
this cycle is repeating itself right
Bram is doing this yet again and so what
happens is that where you have you know
Wolverine and Colossus and storm and all
these characters gathered together in
the X-Men mansion again this is taking
place in the past that of course you end
up having Bram who arrives on the scene
now again there is this kind of
off-handed remark by Kitty Pride where
she asked storm like why don't you do
anything about this rain and just make
it like clear skies and she's like am I
some kind of a meteorologist and the
answer is like yes storm you control the
weather if I were you everywhere I went
would be 75° with a cool breeze right
that's what I would do if I could
control the weather right that just I'd
make it nice everywhere I went but when
Kitty pride gets outside to check out
kind of what's going on especially with
the power going out that Bram is just
kind of standing there and initially it
freaks her out and in fact when
Wolverine goes to the basement to get
candles and comes back upstairs Colossus
is taken out Kitty pride is taken out
right and literally it's just Bram out
there in this demonic form Now by all
standards of measurement right if you're
familiar with New Mutants by all
standards of measurement this looks like
demon bear that's exactly what it looks
like and I would go so far as to argue
it probably is right but like this is an
extremely powerful demonic Force demon
bear is nothing to be trifled with and
in fact it can overwhelm and overpower
Charles Xavier it's one of the most
powerful forces in existence only like
the most capable telepaths have the
ability to overcome this thing the
problem here is that once you switch
back over to Johnny Blaze and Johnny
Blaze is kind of recovering from his
injury after having become the Ghost
Rider he has a sort of demonic Compass
which is to say he sort of knows where
demons are and he seeks them out and
realizing that like there is an
incredibly powerful demonic force on
Earth operating in the Here and Now
specifically at the X-Men mansion he
turns into Ghost Rider and then
immediately goes on the hunt now the
thing about this is because he's Ghost
Rider for the very first time it's the
very first time that he and Wolverine
meet and so where demon bear just takes
off right Bram just like runs off and
that's basically it Wolverine is hot on
his Trail only to run directly into
Ghost Rider and you actually get this
fight between the two of them and it's a
really really really cool moment right
like these two guys duking it out with
each other because a fight between
Wolverine and Ghost Rider is really a
great question of like who would
actually win so I want to know down in
the comment section right if there was
like a knockdown drag out No Holds
Barred fight just based strictly on
their Feats and what their capable of
who wins in a fight between Ghost Rider
and Wolverine because technically wolver
rain does get overpowered here right
like the flaming chains and all that
kind of stuff show up you know Ghost
Riders like I have such sites to show
you right it's that kind of a thing
right like he overpowers the guy and so
I want to know who you all think would
actually come out on top in like a fight
to the death between these two guys but
following this you basically pick up
with a where she ends up finding Bram
just kind of walking down the road and
adido ultimately takes him in there
where he talks about how all he wanted
was a family he didn't want to be left
alone and she realizes that the director
of The Orphanage is just going to get
rid of Bram at the first opportunity
that he gets the only person that really
seems to care about him is AA because
she's emotionally invested and so switch
over to the present day something's
popped off we don't know what it was but
things seemed to go sideways pretty fast
because the house that aah resided in
after taking Bram in has has now all
gone to pot right bram's all grown up
he's like an adult now but the issue is
that he has basically done the exact
same thing he did before which is
twisting everybody's body parts into
like this just monstrosity that
resembles something that you would see
in some Modern Art Museum or something
like that right it's pretty messed up
but with Ghost Rider and with Wolverine
brought together due to this
circumstance yet again the two joined
forces to basically track down and
Destroy one of the most power power ful
demonic entities that's ever existed in
the history of Marvel Comics now one of
the things that they realize in their
Journeys as they come across this just
kind of gigantic crime scene with all
these police lights and everything is
that not every mutant was forced off of
Earth by orcus that some of them
actually went into hiding these
particular mutants were hiding in the
wood now one of the things that I want
to specify is that while Bram is
tracking down and killing different
mutants across the Earth he doesn't
really seem to be Associated directly
with orcus but the ending of this may
very well change your mind and I'm kind
of curious to see how you feel about it
but what goes on here is that in an
effort to at the very least analyze this
crime scene and see what's going on
Wolverine and Ghost Rider actually pose
as what are basically forensics guys so
once they get to like the main crime
scene itself dressing up in disguises
they literally tell the cops just go
ahead and get out of there while they
analyze the whole scene and in that
moment the Ghost Rider tries to manifest
now that's one of the things to remember
about what Benjamin Percy is doing right
now with the Ghost Rider comics it's
very much a return to the old Ghost
Rider stories from way back in the day
which just to say the Ghost Rider
Persona is almost like a demonic
barometer right the closer they get to
demonic or evil or corrupt or somehow
negative energy the more the Ghost Rider
Persona tries to manifest and so In This
Moment it's just kind of frustrated by
the fact that it can't come out and they
can't just wipe out anybody who's doing
anything that's particularly evil now
again that's an important distinction to
understand because in their travels
they're surrounded at all times by
people who were just doing really bad
stuff maybe it's a drug dealer maybe
it's this person doing this or that
person doing that and the Ghost Rider
wants to punish them but because the
focus of Johnny Blaze is literally just
this like Tunnel Vision on Bram It
ultimately forces the Ghost Rider
Persona to kind of keep itself at Bay
but what ends up happening here is
Wolverine calls in a favor with Jeff B
bister now Jeff banister was introduced
to us in the main Wolverine Comics the
only thing you really need to know
within the confines of this story is
that he's a contact that Wolverine has
in the CIA and so what it does is it
allows Wolverine and Ghost Rider to use
a kind of satellite office to basically
analyze everything that's going on with
regards to this mutant DNA any kind of
common trail they may have that may give
them some measure of information now
initially Wolverine's idea is to hunt
down anything or track down anything
that has to do with mutants and it makes
perfect sense just because of the fact
that Bram is killing mutants it's the
best place to start but from Johnny
Blaze's perspective this guy just reeks
of demonic energy so the best thing they
can do is to actually analyze anything
out there that has to do with demonology
right that's the best route that they
can go because while following the
mutant Trail would inevitably lead them
to Bram the idea of Johnny Blaze is
following this Trail will basically get
get us there faster now the information
that they're able to glean is somewhat
helpful but it doesn't give them like a
direct beon instead it basically sends
them on the path to the orphanage that
Bram was at when he was a younger kid
because remember when they initially
encountered Bram in their younger years
they didn't really know anything about
him right like Wolverine met the little
kid at some point but because of the
fight that took place between Wolverine
and Ghost Rider Ram had basically gotten
away right he was removed from the whole
situation and there was no conceiv able
way to locate him again so the best
place they could possibly do was get to
this orphanage and then just kind of go
from there what ends up happening is
that once they get in there the guy who
runs the orphanage initially thinks like
they're cops or they're like reporters
or something along those lines because
they're asking questions about the quote
unquote orphan murders from back in the
day a very wellp publicized event when
it originally happened but as Johnny
Blaze is walking through there the Ghost
Rider Persona tells him to open door
that he comes across which has all these
different locks on the outside when he
does like when he actually opens this
door there's a kid inside who's
basically stuck in one half of an iron
maiden and he basically tells them like
he puts us in here when we're bad and In
This Moment Johnny Blaze plays the game
of yes but maybe yes it's important to
keep the Ghost Rider Persona under
control but
maybe maybe this is a t time to just let
it out so he tells the kid like run you
need to leave uh you don't want to see
what's about to happen next and that's
when the Ghost Rider Persona pops out
because this guy is in effect tormenting
orphans and so wolver rain's response
here is okay something you got to
understand man this room has now become
what we call the truth room and this is
your chance to tell the truth lest you
spend the rest of your days in agonizing
pain and suffering now what we see here
is something that we actually haven't
seen in the Ghost Rider comics recently
and a lot of you guys have asked about
that a lot of you guys have asked when
are we going to see the Ghost Rider do
the pen and stare and that's exactly
what we get it's this amazing moment
right where he says the way to extract
information is through pain and Penance
and he gives this guy the pen and stare
now for those of you guys who don't know
what the pen and stare is it's basically
an ability of the Ghost Rider to force a
person to feel all the pain they've ever
inflicted anybody all at one time now
the pen and stair is used in different
ways sometimes it's used as a form of
punishment and literally it just kind of
leaves the person in a cannatonic state
sometimes it'll kill them sometimes
they'll go insane but in this instance
it's being used for information so I
would go so far as to argue it may very
well not be the fullon penen ster with
the 100% potency that you normally see
because this guy's still conscious he's
still living right like I he hasn't been
driven to the point of insanity and is
like clawing his eyes out of his head
you know out of just complete and total
Madness but what he does is he simply
says somebody was here a month ago
someone asking the same questions they
took the files on brand and so despite
the fact that the files are gone Ghost
Rider is able to kind of see the files
in his own mind because of course this
guy had witnessed the files as well
those memories are transferred they're
of course in turn transferred to rain
and that's when he gets to see the
totality of the nature of brand that
ever since this kid was little right
like when he was first brought to the
orphanage this has been his whole stick
right like going through and basically
tormenting mutilating the whole nine
yards any number of things but just
appearing incredibly Disturbed and in
fact there was a particular instance
here when there was a suspicion of him
having like schizophrenia of course we
also learn his name is Bram stra and so
with this information Ghost Rider in
turn informs wolverin The Man Who
removed the files worked for the
government he had a federal warrant the
address listed should be familiar to us
both hell's Backbone in Utah where we
raced the devil once before right that
took place in the Ghost Rider comics it
was a pretty cool moment because
Wolverine basically ripped a demon out
of Ghost Rider's head it was pretty dope
right but he says it's a frail spot a
place where things spill over a perfect
location for their research What's
Happening Here is research is being
conducted regarding a Hellfire addition
to the weapons plus program which is
exciting for those of you guys who don't
know what this is right anybody who's
been reading Wolverine long enough knows
that like weapons plus like when they
come into the mix that's when things get
amazing because weapons plus started out
as kind of a precursor to project wide
awake right going with Grant Morrison's
X-Men run weapons plus was an
anti-mutant
government agenda that was kind of an
orchestration between the United States
CIA and then eventually Canada's
Department H Captain America was weapon
one right grant Morrison's X-Men
established that and then he got weapons
2 3 4 five all the way up to weapon 10
which is Wolverine also known as Weapon
X the whole idea behind weapons plus is
to basically just create super soldiers
and if they're able to find a way to
harness a being with demonic power that
can turn be used for their own purposes
I mean it would dwarf anything and
everything that came before there's no
telling what could come out of this so
jumping back to the past what we end up
doing is picking up with Bram where he's
brought to really like an old folks home
right hospice and home care and what we
find out here is that this demon kind of
has to feed if it doesn't it'll just
simply seize control of Bram and Bram
will just attack whoever happens to be
in sight regardless of the circumstance
so it's just kind of letting the Beast
loose for a moment and it's pretty dark
because what ends up happening is this
kind of adopted mom if you want to call
her that when she gets there they pay a
guy under the table and this kid in turn
just like destroys this old lady right
the Beast comes out just completely
annihilates her and that's it now one of
the interesting things about this and it
wasn't something that's really been
explored until now Bram doesn't like
this life he doesn't like being
possessed by this demon this this kind
of entity we sort of knew that to a
degree but we didn't really know how far
reaching it was obviously this would
have some kind of an impact on a younger
kid like this but then you switch over
to Wolverine and Ghost Rider right now
of course these two are just flying out
right they're just hauling over to like
the devil's Racing Ground basically is
what it is but they're going there to
find what is an effect this kind of
demonic process that deals with the
weapons plus program now one of the
things we talked about in the previous
video and I think it's worth reiterating
here weapons plus has a long history a
lot of people associate it specifically
will Wolverine but it's much bigger than
that right weapons Plus at least weapon
one was Captain America if Grant
Morrison's new X-Men is to be believed
and then you had just different programs
that came after that that focus on
creating like other super soldiers
following the perceived death of Steve
Rogers at the end of World War II wolver
rain was just the 10th iteration of that
but you've also got Frank Simpson right
then you've got like the Stepford cuss
who are like clones of Emma Frost you've
got phantomx you have all these
different characters that are out there
the recreation or the restruct
structuring of weapons Plus at least as
it's being used here is combining
demonic energy with beings who were out
there that can be used to basically
create super soldiers that have demonic
power but like so many organizations out
there this one is again out for the
mutant population and that's one of the
things that was largely built on with
the work of really Jonathan Hickman and
like the introduction of orcus the
anti-mutant organization the X-Men
taking off to kcoa they made a lot of
enemies and there's a lot of groups out
there that have been dividing their time
and waiting for a chance to basically
destroy the mutant population and while
orcus is responsible for the brunt of
their seeming Annihilation although
again they're not all dead that it's
really kind of cleanup Duty for the
smaller organizations that are out there
right they see it as their time to shine
and so at that point this focuses on the
Learned arrival that Wolverine and
Johnny Blaze are coming and what you
have here is a guy named father Pike and
literally it's just kind of like these
guys are on their way father Pike
doesn't care too much about Johnny Blaze
the person he's after is Wolverine so
again we don't really know how far
reaching this goes with this guy but it
is cool and so at that point you switch
over to Jeff Bannister who was
introduced in the Wolverine Comics as
being what's basically Wolverine's
contact in the CIA as well as a great
friend the issue is he's been doing some
kind of Recon work on the side focusing
a lot on like demonic stories and
information and so on and so forth but
what he was warned about by Johnny Blaze
and really the Ghost Rider was if you
stare into the abyss the abyss will
stare back do not get too deep into all
of this research because you're talking
about demonic stuff right it doesn't
just require you to be messing with
tarot cards in the real life right this
transfers its energy in its Essence
through a variety of different methods
different mediums and one of these can
be through computers and so steering
into this stuff too much suddenly he's
met by not really possession but he's
influenced by the powers of hell now
it's one of the things I love about how
this is done because when you look at
Marvel much like DC there are two sides
of it right you have like the X-Men The
Avengers Fantastic 4 the crazy adventure
wonky stories Spider-Man that you
normally get with like traditional
superhero stuff once you start getting
into Ghost Rider once you start getting
into man thing you start getting into
Doctor Strange to a degree and Wolf Rain
depending on who's writing the story you
get into this whole other Mythos right
where you deal with guys like mefisto
and so on and so forth just like Dam
hellstrom these demonic beings in the
power they possess and so where Jeff
banister is infected by this and is in
fact actually driven to like stab
himself right by all these different
things that Talia Warroad breaks into
the scene now Talia was introduced in
the Ghost Rider comic books and she was
at least an agent for the FBI kind of
working for like their Supernatural
division ultimately they parted ways but
she has kind of been like the sidekick
so to speak and I use that term loosely
for lack of a better word uh but she's
been a kind of sidekick for Johnny Blaze
joining him on his journey as he's
trying to destroy all the different
demons that exist out there in the world
that basically rose up during his
absence but it is cool to see that she's
involved here and in fact she even gives
Jeff banister a little bit of a kind of
concoction that helps to keep these
demonic forces at Bay basically push him
back prevent him from being possessed
and then she kind of warns him like do
not delve too deep into this stuff right
you're like an amateur here you don't
know what you're getting into who knows
what you could unleash out here into the
world it's not for the faint of heart
right so you don't really get a whole
lot with her it's really her just kind
of issuing a warning and then seemingly
sticking around but you transition to
wolver rain and Johnny Blaze once they
get into the facility itself and what
they find here is that unlike in years
past when weapons plus just would modify
human beings or they would turn somebody
like Wade Wilson into what would
basically become Deadpool you know so on
and so forth that what you have going on
is again them trying to create demon
beings right demonic Monsters by
basically restructuring human DNA and so
on and so forth it doesn't really seem
to work but as they're making their way
through here suddenly they're hit by the
helmets of weapons plus these are
basically training helmets they would
throw them on the heads of people who
were basically being subjected to like
mental conditioning that's why Wolverine
says like not again because it's what
they did to him when he was part of
weapons plus it's a way to shut their
minds down but also force them to see
things that aren't there and so on and
so forth and so what we end up doing is
picking up with Bram in the weapons plus
laboratory in the here and now and he's
still much older and he still shuns his
possession here not only that we
actually get a name for the being that
he's possessed by which is B Ghoul Now B
ghoul is wholly introduced into this as
far as I'm aware there's never really
been a presence for his character in
Marvel Comics before my initial thought
is that it was demon bear right like
they look almost exactly alike it seems
like B manifests more as a bear than
anything else but it made just be
because of the kind of Terror that it
instills in humans who see it we don't
really know the whole motivation but
father Pike in speaking to Bram kind of
refers to this as a bit of a gift right
Bram refers to it as a curse and has for
the longest time and even father Pike
says we gave you the opportunity to be
part of an army you have done what we
asked of you but only with the greatest
reluctance so we have enlisted a more
worthy Soldier to take your place now
where Bram recognizes wol rain if for no
other reason than the encounter that
they had when he was younger father Pike
talks about how Wolverine has a
reputation but he doesn't really
understand the relationship between Bram
and wolver rain which is to say they
know each other or at least they've met
at some point in time but what they do
here is they create a kind of process to
allow this demonic transference and it's
one of those things where when Bram asks
like will I be myself again the response
to Father Pike is there will be no more
pain that I can promise right so
seemingly they're going to kill Bram off
guys like Father Pike don't don't make
statements like that unless something
nefarious is going to come out of it and
so following that wol rain kind of Muses
to himself about his own Berserker rage
with his mind kind of being shut down
what it looks like is he's consciously
aware of what's going on but he's there
and not there at the same time and so he
says like Johnny talked to me about what
it feels like when the Ghost Rider takes
over he says it's like watching a horror
movie on a top volume TV that's plugged
into your skull I can relate when rage
finds me I become someone else sometimes
breathing heavy I'll take in the
wreckage all around me the blood
dripping from my claws and hardly know
how it happened I feel the same
potential for Unchained violence now I'm
here but I'm not here they're
controlling me and soon that demon that
Stitcher that bagou or whatever the hell
is called will control me so what
wolverin is talking about here is he's
talking about his Berserker rage right
that whenever wolver finds finds himself
in a heightened state of duress and
loses control quote unquote his Madness
takes over he becomes an animal and it's
the reason why whenever wol rain goes
into a Berserker rage and the X-Men
realize what's happening unless someone
like Xavier or Jean Gray is there that
can use their telepathy to like calm him
down everybody gives him a wide birth
because he does not differentiate
between Friend or Foe and so following
this father Pike basically commences
with the merging of these two guys right
or at least passing the demon entity
from one to the other and following that
Wolverine becomes the hellverine right
literally a demonically possessed wolver
rain he says my veins burn like channels
of lava I feel Jaws gobbling the inside
and the outside of me but somehow I
managed to break free for One Last Stand
before B goul stitches himself onto me
and I become hellverine right possessed
by a demon and he looks amazing and so
simply just following orders what ends
up happening is he is sent by father
Pike out into the world to kill every
mutant he can possibly find five mutants
are detected within 159 miles something
to understand here this is not the first
time that's happened and Wolverine
possessed by a demon is more than enough
to not only Wipe Out the entirety of the
remaining mutants on Earth outside of
some crazy level reality warper but is
also capable of wiping out most all
superheroes on Earth this guy could kill
the world we know because he did it at
one point in time in Marvel Comics but
he's basically set upon the path of
finding whatever mutants he can find
across the world and really the United
States if we're being honest with
ourselves and kill them where he can now
there is a whole motivation behind that
we'll talk a little bit more about that
as we get through this story but this
initially picks up at Cedar City Utah
which is almost in the immediate
vicinity of project Hellfire and again
we'll discuss the nature of project
Hellfire because it's really cool but
like him going on this war path is
really more the result of these mutants
who were basically blowing up this house
because the house was taken from them
now that's one of the things that I do
want to make you guys aware of this is
why I say what's going on with fall of X
right now is very similar to what we saw
with Chris claremont's X-Men run with
Uncanny X-Men and like project wide
awake and all that kind of stuff because
much in the same way that you saw the
mutant population and fighting back for
their own rights really and like the old
Chris Claremont X-Men stories you're
seeing that here and what's going on is
there are a couple of mutants that are
just riding around from neighborhood to
Neighborhood blowing up people's entire
homes they're kind of taking like hot
shots at Humanity Guerilla Warfare
tactics if you want to call it that
right the human race took our homes they
took away our right to exist we're going
to take their homes and their lives
right we're just going to blow the whole
place up with them in it and so this
ultimately brings the atten ention of
hellverine now depending on your
perspective this is a terrible decision
for these guys to be doing because the
best thing the mutant population could
be doing right now is laying low
marshalling their forces and biting
their time because if Humanity truly
believes that they are dead and gone
it's only a matter of time before they
begin to lower their guard and when that
happens you strike right like when
they're at their weakest point when they
believe that everything is safe that's
when you strike because you catch them
completely and total unaware now for
hellverine himself showing up here and
attacking these guys he kills them on
the spot and then he basically starts
restructuring their bodies into this
really grotesque form of art only to
discover that there's actually a baby in
the car and this is when he's given
instruction by father Pike which is take
it out right like eliminate it and
that's where you start to see this kind
of inner turmoil with wol rain now for
his part Johnny Blaze the Ghost Rider
tries to step in but like we covered in
the last video both he and Wolverine had
already been captured and Johnny Blaze
has this kind of mind control helmet put
over his head that prevents the Ghost
Rider from manifesting more so than that
this is how the demon was bonded to
Wolverine just because of the fact that
with Wolverine under their control they
can seemingly do anything they want with
him which includes bonding a demon to
him and sending him out as a kind of
force of nature into the world and so
following that you pick up with Talia
warro and bister now like we've talked
about before Talia isn't really like the
sidekick of Johnny Blaze she's more of
like a person that deals with the occult
that's kind of helping him on his
journey and then Jeff banister is the
contact for Wolverine in the CIA the two
of them are literally hot on the trail
trying to find both Johnny Blaze and
Wolverine but this is when we get some
really cool backstory about the nature
of boul and a lot of you guys called
this in the last video kudos to you for
getting it right I wasn't 100% % sure of
whether or not it was true but as it
turns out bagul was created by the demon
Mesto now the reason why I say I wasn't
100% sure it was true is because there
were demons that existed in Marvel
Comics before Mesto there are those who
came into existence around the same time
of him and some who came into existence
after so it's not as though Mesto is
quite literally the Marvel Comics
equivalent of Lucifer Morning Star from
judeo Christianity right the first of
the Fallen that kind of thing the
original demon he's basically just a
helll Lord and there's a whole bunch of
those that run around Marvel Comics he's
just the most popular one but this guy
created Bou literally just out of sheer
boredom we're told that right like he
was bored by the mundane nature of the
suffering all around him this devil as
we all know has style you can find him
in the finest silks the most decadent
desserts ostentatious architexture
luscious guitar licks and Sumptuous
curves of Flesh sin can be a beautiful
thing now what they're talking about
here in relation to this and this is
kind of a Sidetrack on the nature of
Mesto longtime readers of Marvel already
know this so this is really more for the
new reader Mesto is this guy that will
approach you in any point when you seem
to be your most vulnerable or when it's
the best possible opportunity for him to
strike a bargain with you it doesn't
necessarily have to be something where
like your life is coming to an end or if
you lost everything and you'll do
anything to somehow get it all back it's
not always like that right it's maybe
just some kind of guy out there who
isn't an orchestra and he wants to be
the best violinist and so Mesto will
come to him and he will make a deal and
what Mesto does is he'll give you the
bargain that you're asking for just not
in the way that you think because sure
right you'll become the best violinist
in existence but like your fingers will
be numb right or like you'll lose your
hands in a car wreck or something along
those lines so you have all the skill to
be the best violinist that was ever in
existence you just won't be able to do
it and then when you die he'll get your
soul right he'll collect your soul so he
kind of appears in everything right he's
always out there lurking waiting for a
chance to manipulate people and so
that's why we're told bogra gruul was
created to make art out of punishment
art out of death that is its compulsion
to kill beautifully and erect bloody
monuments in celebration of Mesto so
that's why it does the things that it
does now in terms of why it's going
after the mutant population that's where
Jeff banister really begins to
understand what's going on here that the
nature of really bogra ghoul and the
character of Bram who was introduced to
us in this story as bogra ghoul's first
human host came in the form of the fact
that bram's parents worshiped the dark
and they of course produced Bram in a
cemetery on top of a grave of a guy who
had been convicted and hanged for murder
and so it's like the most sinful act
that a person could possibly engage in
this basically allowed The Offspring
right Bram to become a vessel for B roul
who was just waiting for his time to
take over the boy once they get to
project Hellfire it all starts to click
for Jeff and he starts to realize this
is just a government program that what
the government is looking to do once
they became aware of Bram is basically
harness demonic energy now that's not
uncommon for the government to do and
that's the nature of the projects right
weapons plus and then all the weapons
that came under it weapons 1 2 three all
the way up to weapon 10 and Beyond right
weapon 10 being Wolverine the whole
thing behind this is that the federal
government is always looking for a way
to create some kind of super solder
sometimes that super soldier comes in
the form of a Captain America type
person right a serum that they're
injected with they're exposed to
radiation they come out and they can
just run really fast and punch really
hard other times it's bonding adamantium
to people's skeletons but but any method
that they can use to develop some kind
of a super soldier that can be used in
nextg Warfare they will take they always
contract out in doing so and so
seemingly the federal government is well
aware of what it is that father Pike is
doing but the ends justify the means
because if what they can do is take a
demonic entity and then Bond it to a
living host or an entire platoon of
soldiers they would basically dominate
the entirety of Modern Warfare right
nobody would be able to overcome them so
it is very very shady but it's just the
nature of government programs in Marvel
Comics and so Wolverine who's still kind
of wrestling with this demonic Side and
being ordered to take this kid out he
ultimately rejects it right like he says
no that's not going to happen and he
stabs himself in order to kind of try to
bring himself back to a degree because
remember the way in which Wolverine is
able to regain his senses at least as
best he can is by inflicting pain on
himself and so we're he's told by father
Pike you serve Mesto you serve the
United States government and you serve
me ultimately Wolverine seems to be able
to overcome this if just only by a small
measure and so this leads to Father Pike
basically teleporting out and then in
turn traveling directly to Wolverine
himself now once he's gone and out of
the picture that's when Talia and Jeff
bister show up here and then free Johnny
Blaze from his control and this goes
exactly the way that you would expect
and it's amazing because where helverin
is back on the prowl with control being
retaken by bogra goul and father Pike he
heads towards this town that has 97
mutants in it and understand he will lay
waste to the entire place there will be
no Discerning between innocent and
guilty in his eyes everyone will die if
that's what ends up happening and so
what is going on is that because this is
all done by way of the Mind Control
helmet Jeff banister destroys the helmet
which basically takes away any mind
control that father Pike has over
Wolverine albeit he's still possessed by
the demon entity and then Talia War Road
removes the helmet from Johnny Blaze and
says free the ghost rer right like this
is the only thing that's going to be
able to stop B roul nothing else is
going to be able to end this guy because
remember the nature of the Ghost Rider
is that it was also created by misto but
it was created by Mesto to have just
unrivaled levels of power it's one of
the reasons why Ghost Rider is so
astronomically capable he can go against
the Hulk he can stand against galatis I
mean it's crazy how much power this guy
has so Ghost Rider immediately manifests
and then takes off after wolver rain the
kicker about all this is that with Bram
being the original host and bogra ghoul
being taken away from Bram Bram doesn't
want to lose it anymore and in fact he
wants it back and father Pike actually
kind of agrees to allow it to happen
because what father Pike starts to
realize is that we're Wolverine is kind
of like the perfect killing machine and
under an ideal circumstance he's the
best person to be bonded to this
Wolverine has his own moral compass and
whether it's through telepathic
conditioning from his time with the
X-Men Jean Gray Professor Xavier perhaps
even Emma Frost to a degree or just his
experience in dealing with these kinds
of things he's not allowing himself to
fully Bond right like they can control
him but they can't fully dominate him if
that makes any sense but Bram on the
hand is a willing host and he'll do
whatever it is they tell him to do and
the reason for this is that ever since B
Gul was taken away from him he is just
having an incredibly difficult time
coping he's having an incredibly
difficult time feeling whole he wants
the demon back and so once he reaches
out and tries to collect it unto himself
Ghost Rider shows up crashes into
Wolverine and it's just like so uh we've
been hunting this demon for so many
years tonight we sending him back to
hell and it's like the coolest thing
ever because now it's literally just
straight up Ghost Rider fighting against
this ridiculously powerful demonic force
and bog roul knows exactly who Ghost
Rider is right it's not as though he had
no idea or no knowledge about Ghost
Rider or anything he doesn't really
Express a whole lot of fear here like oh
my God it's Ghost Rider what am I going
to do it's not really anything like that
but it's like you failed Mesto your job
was to be a force of Reckoning on Earth
for Mesto and you turned against him and
you basically became a force that sends
his forces back to hell and so he's like
I will make a monument of your bones for
every demon in hell to piss on and the
response of Ghost Rider is you cannot
punish me because I exist in a state of
constant punishment and I am no one's
servant right and so he says wake up
wolver rain just because you carry
chains does not mean you are a slave to
Mesto which is true because Johnny Blaze
was supposed to be a slave to Mesto he
escaped that fate and then he became a
guy who traveled around the world and
sent Demons back to hell and so while
father Pike is watching all of this he's
just kind of astonished by it all
because wolver rain as the helverin
possessed by boul actually starts to
overcome Ghost Rider and doesn't really
kill him but he seemingly overpowers him
and so father Pike says like come with
us right but the response of Wolverine
is no like I'm done with all of this and
so father Pike pulls bogra ghoul
directly out of wolver rain and starts
to reinsert The Entity back into brand
and the funny thing here is that
Wolverine is kind of able to pull it
back unto himself right and just say no
like that's not going to happen so what
this does is it really introduces the
idea that despite all the power that
bagul has as a demonic entity he's still
beholden to the will of whatever host
he's bonded to which is a great caveat
here it's a great way to explain why it
doesn't just jump from one host to the
next wreaking havoc around the entirety
of the world I do love that right and in
fact that's been an on-running theme in
the Ghost Rider comics for quite some
time and so what ends up happening is
that using this one last bit of power
that he has at his disposal helverin
stabs father Pike right kills him on the
spot using his claws and then in turn
throws him into the fire pits that are
going to send him to hell because what
had happened is he had opened a kind of
portal of sorts beseeching Mesto asking
for M festo's Aid in harnessing and
controlling the power of boul well now
father Pike gets exactly what he's
looking for right like you called down
the Thunder my friend and now you got it
you wanted to see Mesto go see him right
spend the rest of Eternity burning in
Hell misto is going to be happy to have
you there right he doesn't care who's in
hell as long as he has the most number
of people in his section of Hell
following that Bram jumps onto wolver
rain and then immediately starts
absorbing the entirety of Bou into
himself and that's when Ghost Rider
makes this amazing monologue right he
says the spirit is a curse but it's a
curse I have to live with we're entwined
at this point one and the same I know
the writer feels the same as me so as
powerful as Wolverine might be Bram is
home for bwag goul they've killed
together now they'll die together caught
in the punishing light of my damnation
stair now the damnation stair of Johnny
Blaze is a relatively new ability that
was introduced in 2019 but we haven't
really seen it used all that often this
is one of the first times that we
actually get to see it in full display
and it's amazing so there's two things
to know about the damn Nation stair one
is that it is unique to Johnny Blaze
seemingly no other Ghost Riders have it
and this just largely seems to come out
of the point in Marvel Comics when
Johnny Blaze became the king of hell the
other thing here is the difference
between the damnation stare and the pen
and stare so the pen and stare only
works on people that have two eyes and
it forces them to endure all the pain
and suffering that they've caused but it
doesn't work on people like Thanos or
The Punisher because with Thanos for
example he loved it he enjoyed it
because he loves causing death and
suffering everywhere he goes and The
Punisher genuinely believed that what he
was doing was right so it never really
impacted him on that level but for
everybody else they'll just experience
horrible horrible pain and usually end
up in a catatonic State what the
damnation stare does is it judges
whether or not that person is allowed to
remain on Earth or to be sent to hell
and in this instance because of
everything that Bram and bogra ghoul had
done they're effectively locked away and
presumably sent to hell we don't know
specifically how the power works and in
fact the ending of this will give us a
much better understanding of how this
ability functions but once this stair is
done Johnny Blaze reverts back to his
human form and then of course the
entirety of the weapons plus project
Hellfire lab is effectively destroyed
right the whole place is just burned up
and blown up and the whole thing goes
away but while you have Wolverine and
Ghost Rider that go about their own
business you have Bram who's still
locked away as this kind of stone statue
out there in the middle of nowhere but
where a bird lands on this statue itself
Bram is is seemingly still there encased
in stone with his eyes glowing red so
what it looks like is this designed to
just kind of lock a person away but if
they are of sufficient power they are
able to escape again this power hasn't
really been used all that often so we
don't know the ins and outs of how it
works but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you need to get caught up on weapons of
Vengeance make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace